foreign
[Music]
cast number 13. today we are bringing
this latest update from Mac vsog with
stories courtesy of Jocko willing
Productions and of course his right hand
man Echo Charles and today we have a
special technician Carrie Hilton with us
we thank you and without that support
these stories will not be come to you
and today we are having another Green
Beret medic who served in macv sog
and one tour duty but it was a tour of
Duty that has led to two very
interesting books and well actually one
book with a Expanded Edition and then we
have a third book in the work and uh
today I want to welcome to the show Joe
parner Joe welcome to the show thank you
tell it's a pleasure to have you here
and uh you know you and I met many years
ago at the reunion and the during that
time we've come to find out more about
your story which brings you here today
as a Green Beret medic flying first with
Chase and then eventually you wound up
running some missions across the fence
so
um Talk start out with how did all this
begin for you as getting into the army
and then you where you went through your
basic training and then um
let ultimately becoming a Green Beret
medic which still to this day are the
best medics in the world
well
I started off as a student at the
University of Massachusetts I was a
junior
and unlike of many of the students I was
a war supporter
and when we'd go out to the watering
holes and argue about the war I was
always Pro
U.S because I was a John Kennedy fan and
to me you know the expressions like ask
not what your country can do for you but
what you can do for your country indeed
really meant something to me also we
will defend every any friend oppose any
foe to preserve Liberty those things
were things that I believed in they
counted yeah and I got my bluff called
one night when we were out somebody says
Ah you know different than the rest of
us yeah hiding from the draft here right
and I says no I'm not he says well if
you feel that way why don't you quit
school and join the Army and I said
that's what I'm gonna do and I had all
my friends there
and I didn't want to look like a fool
and have them say this guy just is a
bser yeah so I quit school and went to
see the recruiter and uh took tests and
got into the army
and uh
when I dropped out of school it was the
end of April of 66. and uh
lo and behold I got called up for a
draft phys you know a draft exam because
I was no longer a student and wasn't
protected with student status right and
I had a range with a recruiter hey I'll
go in around the end of summer I can
have my last arrive right and I was
gonna do that I got called up for that
physical in a month later or about two
weeks later I got to notice medically
disqualified retest in one month
and the only thing I had to do on the
retest was have my chest x-ray taken
again
so anyway I went for that and it was we
were getting close to August when I was
going and yeah and I never got the
results for that until I was in basic
training
and when I was in basic my mother
forwarded the letter on from the local
draft board and it still read medically
disqualified retest in one month
okay and I was afraid that they'd kicked
me out of the army yeah when I was in
Basics so what I did is I ripped that
letter up into little pieces because you
know they do Shakedown inspections oh
yeah of course and I flushed it down the
toilet in the Barrack
get rid of the evidence yeah get rid of
the evidence so uh for some reason I had
flunked two draft physicals and never
really found out why no kidding yeah but
uh anyway I went through basic at Fort
Dixon New Jersey completed that eight
weeks and then from there we went
directly to Fort Gordon Georgia for
Advance or for Airborne infantry AI AIT
yeah yeah by the way the way I the
reason I went Airborne was a person I
worked Summers I'd worked during the
summer back home and he said to me go
Airborne those guys are tough so that's
why I enlisted for Airborne infantry and
uh anyway Fort Gordon was we got tested
at Fort Gordon for Special Forces
and one of the requirements requirements
at that time was he had to be 20 years
old
and I was like 23 so I didn't have any
problem with that but I remember I maxed
their math exam was 25 word problems I
got a hundred percent and and when when
we went to Bragg they gave us the exact
same test and I got one wrong I guess I
had guessed right the first time
but anyway
then I uh got held all of us going uh to
uh Special Forces get held over for a
couple days at Fort Benning after uh
jump school and then they bust us to uh
Fort Bragg sure and uh there I I wanted
to be an engineer and blow stuff up more
fun yes it was
and the only problem with uh that was
I'd hated KP when I added a few times in
basic and yeah in AIT and I hated that
and uh the sergeant said to me gee well
you know you've got uh physiology
Anatomy from uh College because I was a
physical education major right you'd be
a perfect fit to be a medic you know I
said that was I knew it was 37 weeks of
training right yeah Engineers was like
12 weeks or something or 14 so I said no
I want to be an engineer right so he
says well he says uh
the next engineering class isn't going
to start for about I don't know 12 weeks
or something you'll have KP every other
day oh
it says to me we've got a Medics class
that's starting Monday you wouldn't even
have to pull KP so I went Medics
and Max is the one MOS I knew that I
couldn't do so here you are you're
signed up for it and ready to roll well
things went pretty good in the Medics
I learned a lot going through the
training it was tough training it would
have information fed to US during the
weekend every Friday would have an exam
on that week's uh work and then of
course when you get to the end of
training after dog lab and all that uh
you end up uh having to go before a
board of five officers that are doctors
and one sergeant major was that right
yeah I forgot about the board yeah and
then they they quiz you on anything you
had all year long you know so and during
some of your early phases you also got
quizzes like daily right you came in
you'd be have a coursework and then
you're tested the next day yeah usually
it was the weekly test okay we didn't
really have a spot pop quizzes or
anything like that but you really had to
do your homework though yeah yeah you
had to do something but I was always a
slacker at homework and stuff
I wanted to be the Honor Graduate or
anything like that just get through
right I'm with you yeah
and uh so that kind of uh filled out my
training it was funny when we finished
and graduated it was in December of 67
that we finished uh what was called
phase four then which was you go out and
play Soldier FTX yeah and then you have
to do a 30 mile hike in 24 hours and
after that
you can graduate and then and that FTX
is that the one where it's snowed
uh no but we did have uh water ice on
the swamp that was right near where our
campsite was yeah because our FTX was
the same time okay it's December of 67
and we had we got snow up there we're up
near us oh okay they they did us out at
Camp McCall good training for Vietnam
yeah they did have some snow yeah they
did it with us in Camp McCall and uh I I
remember after we had graduated they
said here list the three places you'd
like to be assigned
you know oh yeah of course and of course
everybody all 43 Medics that graduated
with me Vietnam Vietnam Vietnam oh is
that right i-core two core Three core or
three core too cool you had a choice of
course well
that was our wish list yeah of course
yeah nobody got assigned to Vietnam out
of the 43 Medics oh is that right I got
assigned to the seventh a lot of us to
the seventh to the third to the sixth
some people went to Panama we had a
couple guys go to language school at
Presidio yeah yeah and we had a couple I
think that ended up going to Germany
with the 10th but nobody got there and
you know at that point I had been in the
Army about a year and a half
and I figured hey if I'm going to be
with the seventh for a year I'm not
going to I joined the army to go to
Vietnam yeah and I figured I'm not going
to get there
but we had heard of this angel in the
Pentagon named Mrs Billy Alexander
who they said could get you on the
manifests to go to Vietnam
uh when we graduated we're going home
for a Christmas leave they were that was
right sure around Christmas time and I
wrote A friend of mine Chuck Willoughby
he was the uh nephew of Congressman
Alfonso Bell from California right and
he had visited his uncle the week before
and he had his car with Congressional
plates on it
so Chuck said to me hey you're going to
Massachusetts right up to DC with me and
you can fly from there you know yeah
yeah so we're riding up 95 I think it
was going 95 miles an hour I guess Chuck
figured that that's how fast you had to
go because that was the route number
India it makes perfect sense yeah okay
and uh we
I remember at one point we had highway
patrol car pull up about eight feet
behind our bumper when he saw the
Congressional place he just faded back
into never even stopped us so we on the
way I said to Chuck he dropped me off at
the Pentagon I'm gonna find Mrs
Alexander get on the Manifest for
Vietnam
we got into DC it was about maybe nine
ten nine or ten in the morning yeah so
he drops me off at the Pentagon he hands
me one of his uncle's business cards and
says if you get anywhere in there call
me at the number on this card you know
so
I walked up this there was no signs like
main entrance right receptionists or
anything so I'm walking up a a look like
a driveway with a loading dock and there
was there was a uniform guard on the
loading dock and I got up there and I
was in uniform at the time spec four you
know indeed he said to me uh can I help
you Specialists and I said yes sir I'm
looking for Mrs Alexander
I didn't realize it at the time but the
Pentagon employed about 15 000 people at
that time yeah right you know what he
said to me she's on the sixth card or c
ring no if you go through this door he
says it's going to put you on the e-ring
he says go down till you get to the
sixth quarter go in two more rings and
ask somebody she works in that area the
puzzle Palace yeah so there I am at the
junction of a six card or in the c ring
and this is
there's a no receptionist again you know
I'm yeah looking lost in an Army Major
stopped and said can I help you
specialist and I said yes sir I'm
looking for Mrs Alexander and he pointed
to a little hallway off the sixth guard
or it says go down in that hallway she
works somewhere in that area
so I walked in it opened into a huge
room with about a hundred desks with
people working at them yeah and once
again I'm looking lost in an army whack
major came up and said can I help you
specialist
I says yes ma'am I'm looking for Mrs
Alexander she says see the blonde three
rows in and two desks over I says yes
ma'am she's that sir I says do I need an
appointment to see her she says no you
can go right over isn't that something
so I zigzag between the desks and
introduce myself and she took my name
rank serial number and said see that
room that says E7 and above
she says go in there and wait I'll have
somebody pull your records
so I went in there and guess what as a
sergeant major sitting in that East
Seven and above room and up to that
point I I had no exposure to sergeant
majors and figured they ate spec fours
and PFS yeah for breakfast
so anyway I grabbed Time Magazine
present pretended to be reading it and
uh he piped up
specialist I think the enlisted men's
waiting room is the next one down
I said to him Mrs Alexander told me to
come in here and wait sergeant major he
said oh
My Moment Of Glory was about to arrive
in the army
a whack private came in about five
minutes later and said specialist
planner Mrs Alexander will see you now
really yes that quick yep and he was
waiting to see her too because I later
found out she was in charge of E7 and
above replacements
so anyway yeah yeah uh when I got out to
sit with her uh she
I I told her I wanted to get on the
Manifest and she's well they're not
turning over with the fifth group until
I uh I mean April of 68 right and I said
uh well what what about the 46th company
in Thailand which I didn't know what
they did but I knew they had something
to do with the war because they're not
turning over until August oh wow
I said Well ma'am could you please put
me on manifest for April and she says
well we have openings in April for SOG
do you know about SOG I said oh yes
that's about all I knew about it
so she put me on the Manifest facade the
only thing I had heard of SOG was
everybody that gets killed or wounded
is that right yeah you heard that when
you're going through training groups
yeah and you know we knew that the rumor
scuttlebutt was one of the instructors
had been with SOG and when we got
towards the near the phase four end of
the training there were some classified
classes and so we'd kind of asked is
this what song does over there I don't
know anything about them this is the way
it always was yeah real hush and stuff
so anyway I walked out of the Pentagon a
little Shakey what the heck did I just
volunteer for right I got to a phone
booth now where Chuck Willoughby had
left me off and dialed the number on his
card he answered the phone I says I'm on
the Manifest facog in April where are
you he said I said the phone booth write
down the little short distance from
where you left me off wait right there
I'll be there right so I sat in his
uncle's car they owe the Congressional
plates on it well he went back in and
came back in about 30 minutes and he was
on the Manifest facade too no kidding
yeah he served up at CCN by the way uh
well Chuck was at fob1 okay all right
he's up there with George Bagan yeah and
John Wong yep that's we all we all
gathered there and Chuck had the best
looking mustache in Camp okay yeah I was
always admiring his mustache
he had really good mustache wax tell
them where he got it from
yeah so uh anyway that got me on the way
to Vietnam of course
I I had to go to the seventh until April
well my orders came down in March and
they let me go home for 30 days and then
beginning of April is when I went over
to Vietnam
and uh
I remember I got hell in at in the
seventh I started going like in February
or the end of February to find out if I
uh
my orders were in yet after about a week
this I don't know Sergeant he's seven or
eight or something sister what makes you
think you're getting
uh orders for Vietnam I said well I saw
Mrs Alexander in December and I'm
supposed to you're not supposed to see
Mrs Alexander you're supposed to put in
the proper paperwork blah blah blah blah
blah they came down anyway and so when
did you so you landed in Vietnam in
early April uh a 68 yeah or early April
of 68 and
like I had mentioned to you before I had
that case of eczema that flared up on me
yeah and I looked like a mess I look
like my khaki pants had been had
somebody blow their nose all over it was
they were all
you could see discolorations from where
the body fluids weeped out and uh oh my
God would stick to the pants and oh it
gets better tilt because uh I when I got
along the way uh I didn't something
happened to my security clearance that
they fingerprinted us for in training
group yeah so when I was finishing going
to the seventh they had to redo it so I
could get my in the meantime when I was
with the seventh I had to wear the
little can a little stripe on the hat
not the full flash because I really you
got to have the security clearance to
wear the full flash no kidding yeah so
anyway uh
when you go to Vietnam the fifth group
would make you wear the full flash
though and have it put on when you were
going to Vietnam so that didn't become
an issue but anyway I got to the train
and it became uh
ghetto hang here for your weight to your
for your security clearance to catch up
the it was a
security clearance a secret right to get
the top secret you had to have a a full
uh secret and then they could put you in
for an interim Topsy right we had a lot
of guys without them yeah and uh so
that's the situation I was in so they
put me 24 hours on 24 hours off working
in the transit Barracks at natrang
and one of my 24 hours off I figured gee
maybe this eczema stuff will go away if
I get some sun on it you know I went to
the beach and conked out for a couple
hours and I got really sunburned bad I
look like a Roman gladiator with a
breastplate but it was a big scab my
whole chest ended up being like a stab
right yeah and it cracked and was oozing
and stuff and so I went to The
Dispensary there and uh they said well
they put me on a helicopter send me back
to Cameron Bay to the Dermatology Clinic
this is all welcome to Vietnam yeah skin
issues oh yeah yeah and when I got there
they said oh we'll keep you here through
the weekend if it's not better we'll
ship you back to the States
man that panicked me I went through a
lot of crap to get there yeah right and
here they're going to send me home so I
said to him I'm a medic I says it was
borrow the solution soaks I would have
had to put on it and he says uh I said
give me the medication I says I've got
to work I can't not go back to the trang
you know yeah so give me the soaks I'm a
medic if it's not better I'll come back
it never didn't get better right away
but I didn't go back there I learned my
lesson from that whining about it but uh
it was in the beginning of May when uh I
uh got uh
where we stayed in house 22 and uh you
didn't get any in country training first
no no kidding well maybe normal people
would but see I was I I we're not going
to call you I was in reformed school
yeah but anyway I uh
so you go to the 90 so you get your top
secret briefing yeah yeah and you know
what was really funny because
I had learned enough about getting in
trouble in the Army and we had a major
come up in brief us and he says these
missions are classified top secret never
to be declass oh and wait a minute I
think it was top secret no foreign
never to be Declassified and never
downgraded oh really oh yeah so you know
hey this is
tough stuff then the next guy comes into
full bird colonel I don't know which one
it was could have been Jack Warren
little guy dark hair could have been he
comes in and tells the Humana going to
be some running some of the best
missions in Vietnam someday they're
going to write books about these
missions and I had the real strong urge
to raise my hand and say uh sir but what
about what the previous major said how
are they going to write books if they'll
never be Declassified I know enough yeah
yeah yeah you get KP from that kind of
stuff in there
so anyway then we all got I I was
assigned to fob 2. uh in cartoon so uh
after a day or two of relaxing at house
they shipped us down to uh Khan tomb and
uh once again when we got there uh I I
got there with Bobby Garcia the same day
Bobby Garcia I think you know Bobby yeah
we went through trade group together
yeah and we went to Vietnam again okay
yeah all right absolutely uh we both
arrived the same day and he wanted to go
Recon I wanted to be on recon right yeah
I got assigned to The Dispensary Medics
yeah and Bobby got assigned to the Como
Shack to go and monitor the radio that's
right yeah a lot and stuff and
we eventually formed uh he and a bunch
of other combo guys a support group
where we'd go to the club and cry in our
beer and whine about the fact that they
wouldn't let us on recon like David
Fritz was he there too uh uh Ken
worthley was one of the people sure and
Kenny ended up dying over there on his
extension and Ron bozikas
he ended up dying over there too in fact
the only combo guy that didn't get
killed uh we had a guy named Simmons
that was in our whining group right and
uh
everybody got all of those combo guys
got a shot at Recon and Bobby Garcia is
the only one who didn't get killed
really yeah
yeah good man yeah yeah oh Bobby's was
excellent person
um so uh so you get down to dispensary
and then at some point when he started
riding Chase well the first thing when I
got to The Dispensary was the head
medicate can you get me on a Recon team
no we need you here he said right but he
says I'll tell you he said you'll have
an opportunity to
fly Chase medic which I'll explain what
that is in a second and or you can go
out with some of the hatchet Force
operations and stuff like that because
they needed a medic to go along with
them the Recon teams was not guaranteed
to have a medic correct and uh
the re our I don't know how it was up at
uh fob 1v1 yeah but our Hatchet forces
did not have American Medics assigned to
them they came out of the dispensary as
the missions came up they assign a medic
or two okay go along with it right right
so uh
anyway I
kind of consoled myself I guess I'm
going to be a medic and stuff but I what
Chase medic entailed was we launched out
of fob2 for the 90 of our missions were
run by Huey slicks we had uh I think
four or five helicopter companies that
were supporting us the 57th
the 119th
the uh 170th the 189th and then the 20th
Special Operations
right that was uh the green hornets of
the Air Force and uh usually our
missions were
the helicopter support was for Huey
slicks and four gunships four huh yep
when I first started they were all
Charlie model gunships yeah
yeah and then towards the end of the I
went on recon after that a little while
I'll explain that in a little bit but uh
we didn't get cobras until August
the 360 first uh aerial weapons company
sure something you got coves before we
did oh did really oh yeah oh I didn't
know that yeah but uh anyway uh so I for
about a month and a half I uh was flying
chase you know not every day it was
because just for a listening audience
you have for insertions there would be
two helicopters with the Recon team
there'd be one helicopter with the the
team leader a couple men the second
helicopter right and then there'd be a
third helicopter with a Chase medic so
if anything he got shot down that's
everybody's wounded the medic is there
to take care of them to get him back to
baseball right for the most part we
didn't go down and pick up teams unless
somebody was wounded right there were
exceptions though there were times when
we'd go down and pick up the team you
know part of a team or this uh but it
depended also a lot of times if it was a
real light team six men two Americans in
foreign Dead uh it might you might be
able to do it with just one helicopter
sure just depends on the elevation
exactly how hot it was what time of year
but a 10 or 12 Man team was a two ship
insertion and uh did you have many King
bees down there
we did have King bees but really the
only use
that I recall was when we were inserting
like a platoon or a company
that we'd have right can be support for
those he had a lot of other units
attached yeah sure
so so at some point you go from riding
chair of course riding Chase there were
some hairy incidents because if
somebody's moving on the ground the
Chase has to go in you're the Chase Bank
you jump off and help get somebody in
the helicopter yeah so tell us a little
bit about that side because it first
glance you think oh you're just going
along if something goes wrong it'll go
down help but that's yeah it turns into
a very hairy Mission it can be so
sometimes you have to uh get off the
helicopter and you go and help carry the
person or uh that's wounded in one
instance uh
and this was quite a bit later uh I had
to repel into a crash helicopter
really but it was it was only about four
clicks from Ben hat we were coming out
of Cambodia right uh with a six-man
Recon team in fact they were that
mission was in a way connected with Bob
Howard's Medal of Honor really uh award
yeah uh that whole mission started off
on the 29th of uh December when we lost
the Recon man named should and Robert
sure right and he was in the his uh 1-0
was Gerald appason
and uh the next day they put in uh uh
jerson Howard Robert Grahn and Jerome
Griffin and a bunch of mountain yards to
go and try to get Sheridan's body out
because they couldn't so it's like a
heavy Recon team yep so they put them in
and they got all shot to hell and in
fact they got extracted at night they
had to drop players to light the LZ for
the helicopters to get in and pull them
out wow and it's funny because jerson
was killed he brought a body bag to
bring Sheridan's body out and he came
out in it whoa and uh
so then on January 4th
Gerald Apperson LED he picked up another
American a young guy named Bill Williams
and they went back in to find Sheridan
because they were with him so they would
be the you know sure be able to locate
they're familiar with the with the
target yeah and uh we went and picked we
were pulling them out they didn't find
his body but on the fourth on the 8th of
uh
January we were
we extracted them the first uh Huey
slick from the 170th uh damaged its tail
Road or trying to squeeze down through
the opening in the jungle and the it's
that the ship shot started the shake
violently so they flew back to Doctor
where we launched out of and the second
ship in did get down on the ground and
picked up the six-man Recon team
Sheridan Williams and the indig and they
reported when they were coming out that
they had taken hits in the transmission
warning light was on
and they
some of the other Pilots had tried to
convince the aircraft Commander to set
it down and we'll you know pick it up
with one of the other ships he said no
I'll try to make it to Ben hett he came
up four click sure sure uh helicopter
the road or froze up and it went in
upside down and crashed and the chase
ship I was flying on uh uh landed on
there was a road that went past
Ben hat out past the old French Fort to
The tri-border Junction in that area and
uh he landed on the road and jumped out
of his
you know left seat out of the helicopter
and I figured maybe there's something
wrong with our helicopters you know and
he runs off in the jungle and I turned
around to ask somebody am I supposed to
go with him
and the co-pilot took the ship off so we
started flying you know hovering or low
leveling around the area of the crash
and the door gunner said to me do you
know how to repel
that's nice yeah I had repelled three
times on the practice Tower at the fob
but not from a helicopter that's really
different no yeah I rigged up a Swiss
seat and I rappelled out the only thing
was
the door gonna throw out 150 feet or 120
feet of rope whatever the length of
those were
and
we were only about 60 feet off the
ground and it was bamboo under us in the
rotor wash benthal a bamboo over so it
was like I could walk on it it was like
a mat to walk on no kidding and the Rope
was all spaghettied all over that yeah
yeah so when I got to it I had to kick
my way and fight my way to get through
the bamboo and get to the ground
and it was funny because when I got down
through the bamboo
the lower part of the Rope was now above
me and I had to pull sections of it down
so it would allow me to inch down
towards the ground right and I finally
got on the ground and I I had enough
sense to tell a door gunner lower the
radio to me my PRC 25 radio to me I knew
being on the ground with no comma wasn't
a good situation right so he lured that
down and I had the same problem with
that he got hung up in the bamboo and I
look oh that's the branch that's holding
it up I go there shaking the bamboo and
the enemy's gonna think I'm a Nut here
I'm running around shaking the bamboo
trees and finally I got the radio and I
waved for uh I could see the door gunner
above me and I waved you know get out of
here now and so now I'm on the ground I
take my radio I'm going to call Covey no
answer
I says you know what am I supposed to do
now that I'm on the ground so I I went
towards where the ship was on fire
burning and ex exploding ammunition and
stuff like that grenades and stuff were
going up so I got as close as I could
when I started getting fairly close to
it I could hear the fragments in the
bullets uh shredding the leaves above me
and stuff above my head so I hunkered
down behind like a log Fallen
obstruction and uh
I figured I'll try to call Covey again
right so I got the radio and I got
tapped on the left shoulder by someone
I snap my head around figuring I'm going
to see a flash a muzzle flash yeah right
you know it was an American I had never
seen before
from where
he was on a patrol a platoon-sized suite
they were doing a sweep of that area and
when the ship went down they moved over
to to the crash site to secure it
and he says to me don't go over that way
we're taking enemy fire from over there
right yeah just to follow me so I
followed him
and when we got back with his indeedge
there was one other American I think a
guy named Greer was his name and that
pilot who ran off and abandoned his ship
was there too right really yeah and so
you know there was really a lot of
explosions and secondaries going off
from where the ship crashed sure so
after about 15 minutes 20 minutes uh it
slowed down a little bit and the guy
introduced himself he said his name was
Bobby Dunham and he was on a patrol a
lot of Ben hat and he says that they
moved over into that area
and after about 20 minutes we decided
we'll go and see if anybody alive you
know sure because they were only up
about a thousand feet probably when that
thing went down but I figured hey after
I could walk on the bamboo May mad above
me maybe somebody survived when the
bamboo broke their fall or something but
uh we got there and we found uh Bill
Williams body
his pants were on fire so I had to Pat
that out with my hands and we dragged
him away back to where the other
Americans were waiting Dunham and I and
we saw an indidge laying face down in
the brush
near there so we went back for him
and I remember Dunham took out his he
was taking the guy's legs I was going to
take his chest now we didn't flip a coin
or anything like that on this I was
closest at that end he was closest to
the other and uh he took out his knife
his cape by our knife and cut some brush
between the indigenous legs and the
instant we try to pick that and dig up
something blew up near us
it hit me it blasted me in the right
shoulder it got done them I also knocked
him back we must have been knocked back
about eight feet and I I might have
knocked me out because I remember I was
on my hands and knees I rolled on my
hands and I'm hit I said to him and he
was on rolling on the ground coughing he
says so am I right and I looked and he
had blood coming out of his mouth
so I that led me to believe he was hurt
more than me so I got under his armpits
and was trying to drag him uh back to
where the other people were and then
when we got about half the distance to
where the other people were waiting they
came over and helped us bring him in I
removed his shirt and he had really just
two wounds on him one was in his left
temple
just a small frag wound and one just
below his uh
diaphragm left nipple on his chest and
uh
he kept complaining he said I can't
breathe I can't breathe I told him don't
worry if you can't breathe I'll breathe
for you you know but I tried giving him
mouth to mouth when he said that again
and uh
unless somebody's unconscious it can be
more discomforting to them having
somebody trying to blow in breath shot
to their Rhythm you know so anyway I
stopped that and they called for an
evaction evacuation helicopter and it
was I think from the fourth division
because it had a big red cross painted
on it and it had a jungle penetrator in
it uh and uh so we got done them over to
the Jungle penetrate or when when they
lowered it down and that pilot who ran
off into the jungle straddled the arms
on the penetrator and we loaded Dunham
into his arms and he held him carried
him up to the helicopter otherwise we'd
had to tie Dunham to the to the
penetration right but he really did a
fantastic thing and uh I try to write
him up for an award because he you know
sort of instrumental but the next day I
found out Dunham past died from his
wounds so you know I think many times if
I had been picking up the legs would I
be the one dead yeah so close but yes so
far away yeah
so anyway yeah there were times we had
to get out of the helicopter and right
go and get people and uh
and then from um from your book was
there any of those Medics missions like
where you're still doing chase that kind
of sticks out in your mind today or is
that one that crash there was one of
your worst
uh that was probably the worst crash
they lost the four uh
helicopter crew members from uh the
170th that crashed with the ship right
we lost two Americans Dunham and uh not
done them uh Williams and Apperson
and you know that mission uh Sheridan
was lost jerson was lost trying to
recover his body then we lost all those
people in that helicopter crash
to try to recover one M.I.A you know
so
and uh
there was only really one other instance
that I had to get off the helicopter and
that's when uh Joe Walker he was the one
zero of RT California he was one of our
SOG Legends particularly on a CCC Contin
F will be two yeah yeah Joseph's Amazing
one zero oh yeah
uh
he had I'll tell you a little thing
about Joe we we had a
a team come in and they had been shot
out of their Ron at night uh and uh it
was either rifle grenades or
RPGs that they fired in on them and
wounded some of the people on the Recon
team so Joe Walker had been
playing around with firing a 60
millimeter mortar it was it had all the
bells and whistles taken off to make it
lighter but it was a basic tube it's
basic tube the mortitude and it had a
hand firing trigger on it so he could
trigger on it yeah he could fire it with
a belt around his waist yeah and uh I
remember him staying I hope they hit me
he volunteered a week later to go back
in that same Target and he said I hope
they hit me in the RO in because I'll
have a surprise for us
but that's the kind of guy Joe was oh
yeah so when did you find yourself
finally getting assigned to a Recon team
oh that was uh after I had been flying
Chase about a month
uh towards the end of June I was in the
club and we had a one of our kind of
famous uh one zeros named Pappy Webb
indeed Clarence Webb and uh he was a
scary individual but
anyway uh Pappy had a Vietnamese wife
plus a wife back in the States here
right and uh he lived in a little Hooch
outside the wire with his Vietnamese
wife and he didn't have a lot of money
even though he was in E7 right so one
evening I bought him beers all night
long
in the club and I'm white you know they
won't let me on recon I'm you know doing
my waiting act and at the end of the
night Pappy looked me in the eyes he
said he called me punar
he says panor you really want to get on
recon
oh Pappy I want it more than anything I
told him yeah yeah and
because I'll see what I can do now I had
appeal to a major who was in charge of
the Recon teams when he came into the
dispensary I waited on him and I figured
you know he could do nothing for me he
he tried he came back now you got to
stay here yeah yeah anyway I figured
what's Pappy going to be able to do you
know when the major couldn't do anything
the next day that same major walked in
the dispensary and called me over and
says move your gear into team Texas team
room no kidding you're on Texas but the
thing was Texas had a one Z I mean a
medic that won it off Recon so I was
swapping places with them and the major
explained that he says uh he's got three
months to go in country now when he
Cycles out you're going to have to go
back to the dispensary but I figured the
Army being the way it is they'd never
even remember where I came from in three
months but they did but anyway that's
how I got on recon for a while so who's
the one zero Pepe Webb was initially
when I got there right and uh
uh I I was on Texas I uh
trained with them for about three weeks
and then team Ohio was down to one
American
so I got transferred
after I had never been on a mission with
right with Texas I trained with them but
never never went out they did pull a
mission but uh because I was so green
after about a week I had been on the
team Morris Paul Morris was the 1-1 and
he and pappy went out on a mission and
uh but I never got to go out with them
and it was funny because we were
training the team to parachute jump oh
no kidding yeah static line yeah static
line out of helicopters and I remember I
was really jealous of Paul Morris and
have been all these years he got the
jump over in Vietnam they did a night
jump to start with and they had a day
jump the next day and then they were
qualified for whatever that was you know
and stuff but uh yeah
I really was envious to them but I was
there for their jump their night jump
because uh uh the guy the captain in
charge of the Recon teams at that time
uh uh was Captain illusane they called
him insanelessane indeed I've heard that
name before yeah and uh anyway he came
and said hey will you do the medical
coverage on uh LZ when we do this sure I
said you know yeah I was there when they
did the jump I just didn't get the jump
and then I got on team Ohio and it was
practice mission number one walk out of
the fob pass the mountain Yad Village
off into the woods and play Soldier and
stuff and at that time we didn't have
much for enemy activity around the fob
later six months later it was a
different story but uh mission number
two was uh
by the way mission number one the one
zero his name was Colton and he got uh
malaria or something he could have had a
bad fever so they shipped him off
somewhere and so they brought in Tommy
Carr to take the team over and we went
on a second mission and that was good
practice Mission I learned watched The
Yards how they maneuver how they walk
what they do try to play like you're
imitating them so that was good training
and then we uh we're planning our third
mission and we had a new lieutenant
showed up in only use his code name was
Rocky
and uh he uh took the team over he
didn't move in the room team room with
us so he was rooming with some other
officer
and anyway we had to help him carry his
gear into his new room and stuff and I
thought that was unusual because usually
everybody moved their own gear and stuff
and he took the team over with no
experience and car had already had
experience you know
with uh you know on other teams so
anyway we get ready to go out on a third
walkout Mission and Rocky comes up to me
and says hey Doc what's the dose on
these pep pills he had green hornets oh
no yeah I said sir I says those aren't
vet bills I says if you have to stay
awake at all costs
they'll enable you to do that but I says
uh you know there's some other side
effects here what's a dose on him he
says and I says I want every 12 hours
I think what he did is after we walked
out he had taken one and he wasn't
feeling any effect so he probably
plopped another one or two that night
when we Arrow end about 11 o'clock
I was laying back I had no sleeping bag
or anything I'm just laying on the
ground laying back again yeah and uh
he comes over he crawls over to me and
he pokes me and says we've got a killer
team in our Ron
one of our Indigent dead he says call
into the fob we're only a mile from the
fob and have illumination put over us
right yes I clicked the radio on right
and I think our call sign was Diamond
Head so it was Diamond Head Diamond Head
this is Rocky Rocky over right and yeah
car says shut that FN radio off
and he said right yeah so we're
listening and uh yeah he had told me one
of our indigenous dead his throat's been
cut and everything that's what Rocky
told me
anyway
it became morning there was no dead in
ditch it had rained all night so he's
looking around the ground oh if it
hadn't rained there'd be tracks coming
through here they came through here last
night he was hallucinating from being on
the green hornets we had our mission was
to go out and do a med gap on a village
out there where we heard there was
malaria so we went and did The Med Cap
there was no malaria but a lot of the
kids had like infected cuts and
scratches so I gave out a bunch of bars
of soap and I think I may have given
some uh
erythromycin or something to the Village
Chief and Through The Interpreter
telling them it'll only work if the
village Chief gives it out you know yeah
because you don't want
him to lose face or anything you know so
anyway then we continue the mission and
Rocky's going wild he's going to every
termite Mound we came to and he's taken
a stick and he's poking it into the
holes underneath and he looks around and
said they hide weapons under these
things right
and I was looking at uh a car and he's
looking at me and one of the indig kept
his Temple which is the sign of dinky
down yeah so when he Tommy Carr told
Rocky I'll get us into a place where
nobody will get in come through there at
night so we crawled into a bamboo
Thicket
and we we even to lay down we had to
quietly pick sticks out of the way so we
could lay down so Tommy coward had had
our little uh areas cleared and Rocky
immediately
fell asleep because he hadn't slept for
two days now you know yeah yeah so he
Laden crashed right away right and just
before it was getting [__] that's
going uh uh and crashing through the all
the bamboo and cracking and stuff I said
to myself if we were over in a hot area
in Laos now we're all dead
that you know that kind of actions you
just don't do
and uh
so we got back from a mission after that
they you know rained the whole time we
were all soaked so we got back to the uh
um
compound and the
guy that was overseeing at that time the
uh Recon teams came to me and said uh
get your gear ready I'm sending Rocky
out with a hatchet platoon tomorrow and
I want to I want him to get some
experience with
platoon and I told him I says I never
want to go out with that man again
is why
and I explained to him exactly what had
happened and so he said well tell him
your gear is all wet and I'll get
somebody else you know so then he ran to
Tommy car right away and Tommy kind of
says yeah that's what happened he's I
wasn't going to say anything about it
because I figured everybody would think
it's
uh you know I'm just mad because I lost
the one zero slot to him so he said but
yeah that's what happened right
so anyway I'm going to ciao and uh I'm
coming back from ciao and I bump into
Rocky
says to me hey how come you're not
coming out with me tomorrow what's the
matter you chicken and I said to him yes
sir I'm chicken
no no no he says I saw how you handle
yourself out there why won't you come
out with me I said if I told you you'd
only get
ticked off so yeah and he says no I
won't no I won't tell me tell me right
so I told him I have absolutely no
confidence in you as a Recon 1-0 and I
think you're going to get people
needlessly killed and I don't want to be
one of them whoa and so then I went to
the showers to take my shower after the
mission I'm getting out of the shower
here comes
uh the captain
he says to me I thought I told you to
tell him that your gear was all what I
said I did but I says he wouldn't accept
it for an answer and demanded another
answer right he says uh how's he
supposed to gain confidence if you tell
him you don't have confidence in him
I says sir this isn't the place to come
and gain confidence if you don't have
confidence in yourself to begin with you
shouldn't be here yeah at all he said
you ever disobey another order from me
and blah blah blah blah blah blah
and you know under my breath I said some
stuff not out loud you know indeed but
anyway that was the officer Corps yeah
yeah so uh anyway Tommy Carr took the
team back and stuff and we ran a couple
decent missions we ended up uh
destroying an enemy bivouac area that
was in Vietnam
uh was that close to the Border area or
does that no it was bed head or anything
like that where we had a radio relay
site on a mountain between like Contin
and Cambodia not Leghorn nope the
Leghorn was out in Laos this was uh
called Sledgehammer oh right right yeah
but Sledgehammer when I was over there
everybody says oh it's in Cambodia it
was not in Cambodia it was in Vietnam
but it was a prominent
Peak yeah that could make good radio
contact with the people running in
Cambodia yeah uh but it was just between
that and gone too
and uh we found a grave
an enemy grave there in the bivouac area
it was like three uh Banana Leaf covered
structures that could probably sleep
maybe a company of people who were like
three structures and stuff so we radioed
back and uh today we found something so
they order us move a mile up that
Hillside right then we got up there call
artillery in on it right so we called
artillery in on it then of course when
you're done with that it's go back and
see if we hit anything no he had to do a
bomb damage assessment yeah we had to go
back yeah after and then it was dig up
that grave maybe maybe that's a cache of
weapons or something you know we dug it
up it was it was a dead body in there
and uh
so anyway that that was a fairly decent
mission in my last experience on recon
was Tommy Carr was too lazy to run the
we used to run sweeps Around The
Compound on nightly security well we had
a road that ran through the compound and
separated it into East and West and one
Recon team would go out about a mile
half a mile and run an act around the
compound back to the road and the other
would do the same thing on the opposite
side so I got my time he says I want you
to get experience being a 1-0 right so
he said you take the team and we had a
new uh at night
well it was it does it wasn't dark out
at the time right so anyway so uh we had
an
a new uh
guy on the team Luke Dove he in fact
he's of course remember here in uh he's
an attorney yeah he was our platoon
leader training group oh okay yeah yeah
Mississippi yeah yeah yeah well anyway
Luke was
yeah yeah but I'm in charge right so we
get out there to do this sweep and all
of a sudden we get pow somebody's firing
off a shot wow another shot
so uh we radioed back to the fob hey
we're hearing shots out here we'll go
see what it who's shooting you know so
me being an experience I said to The
Interpreter we go catch them
and he said something to the point man
the point man starts running in the
direction of their shots right everybody
else that's following I'm the I'm wait I
mean go slow you know I meant to say but
I never said that right I learned then
you better speak be specific when you
tell these guys you want to do something
anyway when I finally caught up to them
they had the guy that was doing the
shoot and it was some poor old mountain
you had up there that I think was on the
local uh militia militia yeah he had
birds in his shirt that was his supper
right
so anyway we radio back we got the guy
he's got a bunch of birds in his shirt
we'll bring him back in for questioning
man we ruined that guy's whole day
we brought him back in and that was my
one experience at being a 1-0 oh my god
well then also in base
um after they closed that for B1 they
rotated some teams that came South yes
they did and amongst those was uh uh RT
Louisiana with John Walton yes and he
was one of several people that you had a
very interesting medical class of
graduates that came out of that he was
in that class of 43 Medics that all
volunteered to go to Vietnam but you
know after we after Willoughby and I got
back to Bragg we told everybody Mrs
Alexander really exists and can get you
there and everybody was calling her on
the phone after that you know bugging
her in fact Brian Locs called her up and
says I want to go to dog she said we
don't say that over the phone
oh my God so yeah
you want me to jump ahead a little bit I
can continue where John Walton got
transferred back sure uh yeah when they
closed full bite down I think it was
correct John's team came down and John
got assigned out at the mountain yard
Camp which was about
couple miles south of
fob2 right or CCC I think at that time
that part of transition at that time
yeah yeah so anyway he was out at the
yard Camp when he had about a month left
to go it was beginning of March he moved
his gear up and was going to move in
with myself and Brian locks another
medic and I figured man this might be a
record of some kind we got three Medics
who graduated in the same class a
roommate so their last month in Vietnam
you know I'm still alive yeah and still
alive you know so uh
but it never came to be because uh
John went and got he liked to play poker
right and he went to the club and got in
an all-night poker game
and so I left the door unlatched and uh
um went to sleep lox was sleeping in his
bunk and we started getting some
incoming
I could always tell the incoming by the
sand tinkling off the metal roof sure uh
after impact right after impact sand
would be sprinkling down everywhere and
it was I could hear the sand tinkling uh
on the roof so I said to Locs get under
your bunk it's incoming
well Lokes figured I'd better get to the
wall so because the sirens started
wailing too so he starts pulling his
pants on sitting on his bunk
and I looked up at the the open door and
said oh I should maybe I ought to get up
there real quick and Go latch that
because I don't want a sapper Squad to
throw over satchel charges and they're
like we had it decided yeah before
August 23rd 68. so that while I was
contemplating whether I should do that I
didn't the door was gone a second later
a b40 RPG went right through our room uh
blew the door off the the hinges and we
had a double two by four jam on the
right side of the door away from the
hinges that got blown out we had about a
three foot hole in the center divider it
was Masonite like that separated our
rooms from the rooms on the other side
of the building and on the fire concrete
wall which went up about four feet there
was a eight inch hole from the shape
charge where it exited the building yeah
and uh
luckily there wasn't room for both John
and myself under my bunk where I was
hiding
so he was lucky that was the luckiest
poker game I think he ever was because
he was playing poker on the other side
of the highway right yep so he he
survived that one and I can remember
talking to him the night after that I
was afraid to sleep in the room because
I figured
they repaired the room in one day the
only way you could tell something hit
was the corrugated metal would bowed up
above the door in a couple of spots with
a blast right had meant the you know the
steel roof there it dented it up but
they repaired it that day and I I didn't
sleep in the room I slept out on the
wall in the I had an indigenous sleeping
bag but it was it uncomfortable on a
sleeping on a skid you know basically
was the bottom of the bunker and so then
I
talked to John and I
he says well I think the chances of a
rocket hitting the exact same spot are
pretty slim or something like that
that's a good one he's always playing
the odds yeah you know the odds so so I
went back to the room but
and by that time John had been running
missions out of fob one yeah came down
by the time he was the 1-0 yeah yeah
yeah
he was awarded a silver star up there
yeah for August 3rd with Tommy had his
leg blown off yeah yeah and uh uh
you know it was funny because I uh John
Walton we were all derosing at the same
time right and uh we all flew together
to
natrang where we signed the
non-disclosure
agreements decided after the tour Duty
yeah no kidding yeah when we left with
he briefed us at uh natrang and they
told us slows EU and the special
projects you've trained Mountain yards
that's your cover story for what you did
over here you know and so uh
I remember it was ten thousand dollars
fine ten years in jail or both but I
don't remember whether it was 20 years
or ten years twenty keep your mouth shut
or whatever I remember the 20 something
good all right my address at home was 20
West Paul 11 it's like okay all right so
it's stuck yeah and uh most of us
stuck by the non-disclosure statements
that I know of I know of one case where
somebody didn't in fact they're in the
Pentagon papers so blabbing about
us doing
missions and Laos and stuff like that
but so you served your three years
I said yeah I served two years and eight
months in the military they kicked me
out because I had less than 150 days
they threw me out in civilian like so
where'd you go from here Joe
uh
you mean in civilian life yeah oh I uh
tried teaching and the kids ate me up
it was different from when I graduated
you know the things that students were
saying to me yeah you'd have been home
for a month there's an attitude change
yeah there was an attitude change and I
was told in one instance a young lady
said something to me and when we got to
the office and were together with the
principal she's oh he thought I said
something but I said something else you
know and of course neither one of us
said would she really said Fox taught
something indeed yeah you know and uh
so uh
when she left he dismissed her and he
said to me can't you look the other way
once in a while she comes from a rough
family
you know I practically
wanted to tell him I can look the other
way all the time if that's what you want
but the superintendent of schools writes
me up because I got a kid looking out
the window
yeah yeah
so after four months of teaching I quit
and went back to working in the machine
shop and you know it was funny because I
had a job piece work and a machine shop
making I was making like 250 an hour and
uh
130 dollars a week my pay as a teacher
was 102.50 a week
whoa
but my I was married at the time my
first wife liked that because it was
more prestigious than being a grease
monkey pulling down a drill press handle
all day indeed yeah wow so anyway but I
have no regrets about serving in Vietnam
or I'd do it all over again well and as
a medic too when you would go out into
those
um you would go out to the local
Villages yeah that's a major yeah
because that's a major win the hearts
and Minds kind of thing because the
Medics are the people that established
the report wise children and any of the
men are sick they're able to rebound
heal correct and um you know the vehicle
would never do anything like that that's
a whole special area not only is it good
medically for The Villages but it's
psyops at its best yeah in a really
sincere way
yeah
it's amazing and that's where the Medics
training can be everything from
delivering babies to helping cure
syphilis
I got to a company a hatchet platoon to
recover a wiretap on one Mission and
that was really an interesting Mission
because we got really close to a bunch
of NBA
we we took in is this Cambodia or Leos
with Cambodia
and uh
a Recon team found a wire and put a
wiretap it was like a suitcase size
device where they'd clip into the oh
it's a the big one yeah yeah several
different side we always carried a small
cassette recorder oh okay and
periodically a plane would fly over and
it would relay whatever messages had
come over to the plane but it said
stopped transmitting so they put in the
hatchet platoon to go recover it and
when we got in there we were inserted
about three
ridgelines north of that three hill
Hills North of that and as we were going
up the the side of it we've hit a trail
with had bunkers built along the side of
it periodically uh and you know
well-used Trail and was sneaking up the
trail we could hear people cutting wood
off to the side in talking
and so we 30 of us are crept past him up
to the top of the hill when we got to
the top of the hill we heard this
strange sound like hey crack oh yeah
crack
and we're wondering what the heck all I
could picture is somebody with a piece
of shattered bamboo doing practicing
karate chops on it but
so we sent some people you know martial
people up to see what it was and it was
a whole bunch of NBA out in the open
doing drill with their rifles the high
air was a command and the crack crack
was the people slapping their rifles
and so the the lieutenant that was
leading us
said we'll turn around and go back down
the trail the way we came when the word
got to the end of the the you know the
American and the
um
at the tail element yeah
the guy came forward and says hey we
heard those guys saying we'll get them
when they come down
so we angled off that Ridge line
and went into a like a little Valley
with a small brook in it and up the
other side of the hill and stopped there
and started calling in artillery on that
Hilltop
we we got we had a Covey Fly Over Us in
fact in Stars and Stripes it was written
up in stars as Stripes as being in
Vietnam
and the guy's name was Morton and he was
with the Headhunters some uh group of uh
you know the bird dog Pilots is that
right yeah that uh his name last name
was Martin yeah and when our uh Como guy
talked to him I think Luke Dove might
have been the cubby writer that day oh
no kidding with him yeah because Luke
recalls when they were they saw a whole
bunch of people on the ground doing
drill like yeah so uh anyway uh uh we
called in air strikes for almost the
whole day and what a show that was uh
they got fast movers from some aircraft
carrier to come in and expend 500 pound
bombs how's the Navy yeah were they good
well they got one of the 337 mic mics
that was popping at them and there we
are about 300 meters probably from where
that
enemy encampment was and uh you could
tell when the jet was coming in to make
a run because it was uh
37 mic mics and there were three of them
you know simultaneously going up plus a
51 caliber plus all the AKs up on that
hill to help with started shooting then
they'd stop
and then there was like about a few
second pause in this about boom where
the bomb would go off
and uh
the Morton reported that that's more and
more enemy he's ever seen out in the
open over there really yeah and so we
called airstrikes in all day on them and
uh then it got dark we arrow and right
where we had we're calling the strikes
then from the next morning we tried
calling an airstrike there was no return
fire
so then they send us go find the wiretap
now that's too Ridgeline two two Hills
South of us now right so yeah sure we
got down there and uh the one of the uh
people from the Recon team that had
planted the thing found the spot where
they had put it but it was gone
evidently the enemy found it and uh
there was no comma wire there anymore
either to to tap right and just inside
of there there was a road like a
dirt road that's
skirted the border the Cambodian border
so we were on the Vietnamese side of
that road about you know 20 meters in
the jungle and we followed it North to
where we found
another little side road going up and it
went to that Hilltop that we called all
the airstrikes then on and we found that
they had three 37 Mike Mike positions
they were all gone they moved everything
out at night
and there were three 37 mic mics laid
out in the form of a triangle and if you
can figure those three points where the
guns were if you drew
like trenches in towards the middle like
spokes on a wheel almost uh that's in in
each one of those spokes there was a
little tunnel dug off to the side where
the enemy could hide during the
airstrikes and we had a 50 uh 500 pound
bomb crater that
half overlapped the uh 37 Mike Mike pit
and we found the recoil spring from the
37 Mike Mike that evidently got
destroyed and uh I picked up one of the
empty 37 Mike Mike casings for a
souvenir and put it in my pack and
evidently they had a barber shop there
because we found human hair in several
places no kidding yeah no I think it was
probably people got wounded real bad you
know sure but uh uh that was that was a
good operation we got really close to
the enemy and then we got extracted uh
late that same second day so you went in
with a full platoon on that yep yeah we
had a platoon to go and retrieve that we
never got the white app back but we got
in close to the enemy and we put some
hurt on them because oh yeah of the
airstrikes and uh we started walking
artillery up the with the trail we had
walked up to to get to that Hilltop sure
sure we heard the people chopping wood
and uh
I was never impressed with artillery uh
over there with three rounds at a Time
Boom Boom Boom boom boom boom was that
right yeah my my you know
on a recon mission with Tommy Cara we
had called in artillery and I remember
he says okay fire around they fired
around and then finally he told me okay
tell him fire for effect and I figured
the whole valley was going to go up and
gunfire three rounds at a time coming in
in like a minute in between for the next
Salvo to come in and I was just about
Hollywood has got a lot better
artillery than the Army does
so what do they use like 155s and once
yeah I think they were 150 and they were
firing on out of I think it was
plagiarang
uh where they had a lot actually with a
camp down there so they had plenty of
experience with the
artillery there maybe yeah a little bit
more
thorough yeah
and I got to accompany one slam
operation in fact you know in uh slam is
searched locate annihilate monitor I
don't know what the heck the monitor who
monitors whether it's like a BDA after
you're done yeah assuming you wipe
everybody out and you're in a good
position I always figured maybe you get
wiped out and then who monitors yeah
because those slam misses drew a lot of
attention from the end yeah well this
was 14 to 19 uh November of 68 the slam
that I was involved that's probably one
of the first ones right it was the only
one according to government reports I
have that was conducted in 1968. right
the only slam operation and it consisted
of like four company size operations I
don't know four or five platoon size in
13 Recon team operations
that started with Joe Walker on a
prisoner snatch in his uh trigger man
his gun uh didn't fire when he went to
to trigger the Ambush on the Annie yeah
and the enemy had grenades mounted on
boards on their chest
and they also had an RPD machine gun
with them and that opened up and they
started
peeling the grenades off the chest two
at a time and they hit Joe's 1-1 Terry
Brent's and he got a bad head wound
and that was a time when I had to get
off the helicopter to help get unloaded
on and uh that after they
in order to secure the LZ for that they
put in a hatchet Platoon
so now we've got a hatchet platoon and
all but one of a Recon team in there and
uh instead of pulling them out it became
oh see what else you can find you know
roam around and explore is that right oh
yeah that was on when we pulled the
wounded guy out it was the 10th of
November
and on the 14th uh the hatchet platoon
got overrun with Joe Walker's team they
overran him really and yep and on the
14th when I got into the dispensary uh
they asked me as you get ready to go
report to the choppers that going to put
in a company to get out the overrun
platoon
and uh Joe Walker got wounded that day
and we had a black and spec 5 named
Bryant
and uh
he got badly wounded in there and uh
when they got the first half of the
company and I went in with the first
half of the company it took like eight
helicopters two flights from doctor to
get all those people out there about 120
people
and uh so when we got on the ground I
remember going over to Joe Walker and
says boy if anybody's still alive up at
your Ro Insight across the river
they probably need medical attention he
said I'm going up there right he just
walked up to the uh captain in charge of
the slam and said I'm going up the Ron
site and he headed across the river and
Bob Howard was there and Bob says I'll
go and so he joined us and we found
Bryant there were five dead indigen they
had dug foxholes as a duned uh the
previous night and uh we found Bryant
still alive in his Foxhole but he had
like 19 wounds in his body 19. he's
still alive yeah he had one
Black and Blue Streak running on his
forehead
for like right above his eyes
and he said he was conscious when I was
putting bandages on all those holes and
he said in the morning the NBA came
through and shot all of the Dead
and he says they shot him in the head he
said I just played dead
whoa and uh we ended up getting him out
of there I put an IV in him because when
I opened up his shirt it had a about a
quart of blood in there with a big clots
formed in it yeah yeah so we got him out
of there and everything and now they've
got a whole you know whole bunch of us
in there they got maybe 130 people and I
figured hey we we're successful we
pulled out the the survivors of the
platoon and they're going to pull us out
now
they had different thoughts hey we got a
fresh company out there and let's raise
hell in the hotel and they had been
popping at us with 37 mic mics from
about two miles probably to our
Southwest
so then it became oh let's go see if we
can attack those they'll have to stand
and fight if we attack those you know
they won't be able to run away on us so
uh it became a quite a quite an
operation
uh I didn't bring you know I smoked
cigarettes back then and I ran out of
cigarettes after about the first day
we got hit with rifle grenades fired in
us that was on the 14th we got inserted
on the 16th they hit us with rifle
grenades we took about 15 people wounded
uh about 11 of them were enough to
so at that point were you working with
the Air Forces some of the traffic would
back up on the highway then the Air
Force would come in and attack the
backed up traffic at once we walked
right down one of the major branches of
highway 96. so when you walk down 96
where you're smoking cigarettes I mean
the hatchet force is so much different
than Recon why not they know you're
there
exactly and uh uh I remember where you
know what they were doing is yeah the
guy leading us uh in fact the guy
leading us his name was Tom Yeager he
was at the sore just recent this past
year our past Virginia a couple days ago
then last night yeah and he uh he was
also on the Sante prison raid back in
1970s November 70. yeah in in uh he led
one of the assault uh elements with dick
Meadows
uh I think dick Meadows ran one assault
element He had the other one or
something of course then dick Meadows is
still the all-time Legend
absolutely had what 12 or 13.
we captured values oh yeah he I think he
holds the record for most prisoners
taken of anything absolutely just yeah
crazy never oh yeah no he was he was a
legend in his own time absolutely that's
before then he gets promoted to officer
B and later yes he's doing the
commission yes Recon team company
Commander yeah yeah yes sir yeah oh my
God and in fact on this Mission Bob
Howard was put in for the Medal of Honor
on this slam operation but it was
downgraded to a silver star wow but
that's one of the first two rejections
then so this is because it had the heavy
contact by now you got the nva's
attention they're coming at you with
heavy weapons now
more platoon or squat size well we we
needed a resupply right because
everybody was out of cigarettes and
stuff of course they're really important
stuff
so anyway they uh told us that was the
uh
57th was uh Assault Helicopter Company
and uh I I've talked since to to the guy
who was dropping those two bundles to us
they oh we got the word they're going to
drop two bundles to you and you'll have
a mortar in the resupply and we're
thinking we got enough to Lug without
lugging a mortar base plate and all that
kind of stuff you know so they dropped
one bundle and it landed probably half a
mile away the second one was maybe 100
meters from our where we were located so
Howard and some people went to retrieve
that right they brought the bundle back
and it was a wooden crate it set on that
mortar ammunition
and I remember somebody commenting great
we got the motor ammunition to carry and
Charlie he's got the mortar
we opened it up and it was all full of
cigarettes still
everybody was happy yeah my first
cigarette I lit up I got dizzy from it
because I hadn't smoked for a couple
days you know you know I forgot how
difficult life could be on a hatchet for
us yeah so anyway we needed them to
still be resupplied with ammunition and
stuff sure we moved on to another open
area and oh maybe a hundred yards long
50 yards wide and we set up a perimeter
around that open area and they flew in
and gave us water in these plastic bags
they were maybe a six inch in diameter
and five feet long
a bunch of those bladders they dumped
off they gave us ammunition food that's
where I first started to learn to eat
the PIR rations sure the indige rations
yeah yeah exactly they were good I liked
them me too they're fabulous during the
resupply uh when they dropped off one of
the helicopter loads one of them we got
hit on the LZ and I was helping carry
stuff up to where we were going to ro in
shortly off the LZ and uh one of the
Yards got shot right through the elbow
oh and uh uh they had put a like a a
tourniquet on his arm right so I went up
and put a pressure dressing on it and
tried to uh I figured he's going to lose
his arm if that tourniquet stays on all
night because it was close to dark so uh
I put a pressure dressing on it put his
arm in a sling and uh
I stayed up all night every
10 minutes or 15 minutes I checked the
dressing and about oh maybe one two
o'clock in the morning
what I use for backing to put pressure
on the wound was an a combat dressing
still in its plastic wrapper right that
had slipped off the ties that were
holding it down so his
dressing was all wet from blood he was
bleeding so I had to put one on in the
dark and
no sterile technique until all by feel
okay this is the bone put it here put it
there and I'll tie it and I stayed up
all night taking care of him and we got
him out at first light and then we
continued on and got ambushed in a big
open area
companies of NVA ambushed Us in there so
you're on a road at the time
no we we had we were coming through the
jungle but it you know it became
because they could tell us oh yeah Tall
Grass to knee-high grass not Triple
Canopy like that and then Highway 96 or
part of it went right through and went
to the left but there was a little side
road that headed more in the direction
of the 37 Mike mics that had been
shooted from so we started following
that and when we got
almost to the other side uh
Lieutenant Yeager told Bob Howard and uh
we had a first lieutenant named Lee
Swain
and he told them uh to uh
kind of take point but he didn't want
both of them on point because that was
his that was his company sergeant and
his one of his uh top platoon leaders
you know so but they they were up front
and uh they saw people enemy moving in
the Woodline and so they uh
I guess Lee Swain said to Bob Howard up
you know should we initiate it now and
one of the two of them said yeah let's
do it now right so they dropped down and
started shooting at the figures in the
wood line and a rifle grenade came out
and went off right between
Swain's feet when he was laying down and
it took off one of his ankles and left
it hanging by the Achilles tendon
and the other one is like you ripped a
big chunk of his calf out
um
and so I was near the end of the column
they always stuck The Meta down back so
we couldn't see anything
and uh
I went to the uh
got an American about three Mountain
yards away from me it says
are we in contact I fired a couple
magazines I didn't see any return Fire
coming so I said asked him are we in
contact he says no I think we're just
having a mad minute he says let's go up
front see what's going on the front of
the column was really in contact
then we we ended up calling so you get
that stressed out that far you couldn't
you couldn't hear the the noise from the
contact yeah yeah yeah
and uh so anyway then when I got to
Lieutenant Swain I remember looking down
and seeing the pearly white bone ends of
his ankle bone separated and he just
being held on by the Achilles tendon I
almost fainted felt I believe it I had
to tense up all my muscles to keep from
pain I figured if you faint you might
start a chain reaction everybody's gonna
faint and we're all gonna get killed
time to toughen up yeah oh my God and so
so you had so you treated how do you
what do you do with a severed foot I'll
tell you you know normally what I should
have had done is split that
[__] you know what I mean
but hey we got we were calling in CBU at
that time the cluster bomb years yeah
and we had trees within our right inside
our perimeter with a tops of them were
being blown off by the CBU because we
had uh the cubby could see that we had
enemy massing to attack us just in a
ways into the tree there were other
homes so would that be like by there is
a double canopy
at all in that area uh
might have even been like bamboo and
stuff was just single canopy but you
know not just grass or sure or elephant
grass that was taller than that uh but
we uh
then we had to try to get somebody into
Medevac uh uh
Lieutenant Swain because he and we also
had another uh person who when when he
was kind of he had moved into the wood
line a little bit when
the
spads dropped
the CBU right and he got wounded from
that and when I uh because I was
treating a mountain yeah and this yard
came up to me and says American wounded
so I
showed the guy the guy's friend who
brought the wounded Mountain out I was
treating how to hold pressure on his the
whole side of his face was like peeled
down so I showed him how to I eased it
back up with a dressing under it and put
my hand over his hand and showed him how
I at the press and so I come back you
know and then I followed the other yard
we found a sfc named Dickerson who had
seen in the club but never really talked
to or met and he was on his haunches
thing when I got to him I said it's the
medic I he's I can't see I can't see
right so I said we're going to bring you
with with where the other wounded are
right so the yard picked up his weapon I
grabbed him under one armpit the yard
under the other armpit and we dragged
them letting his feet track facing
rearwood he wasn't really brought him
into our perimeter I remember when we
were bringing him into the perimeter I
could see you know where our people were
spread out I could see machine gun
bullets kicking up the dust in the
middle of our perimeter no kid okay yeah
and uh so uh anyway then we had needed a
Medevac so it was the uh 57th that was
supporting us once again sure and this
pilot named Carl Hoke
uh
tried to get in to get Lieutenant Swain
out and he got shot down the enemy moved
up with a tracked vehicle with 50s with
a 51 caliber on it and shot
Carl Hope was the name of the pilot from
a 57 shot his helicopter down
and the chase medic was on it I named
Tony Dorff he used to be a member of the
organization but passed away not long
ago but uh
anyway he got shot down so Howard and
Tom Yeager who went
guided them back into our perimeter and
uh
then luckily just before it got dark we
did get two helicopters in to get out
the most critically wounded because I
figured man I can't treat all we had
what happened to Dickerson if he
couldn't could he really not see or was
it just being stunned from them
I was I was concerned most about the
wound he had in his chest sure and I
watched it for a while to see if it was
frothing blood-like but I didn't see
anything like that but I treated it like
a sucking chest wound took the plastic
from a combat rapper taped it to his
chest and uh
so anyway
he he survived all right and uh luckily
uh the guy who tried to do the resupply
of the by dropping the bundles to us the
day before he's the one that came in and
ended up getting Lee Swain out
and Bob Howard and myself and Tom Yeager
were the ones who carried Lieutenant
Swain to the uh Chopper and got him on
there and they got out and then it was
ready to get dark so we had to spend the
night in there and camp out there was a
ring of foxholes right and the yards had
dug and I noticed nobody was using one
of the foxholes I went over it and there
was an unexploded CBU on the bottom of
it
so right this American the one next says
I'll come over here with me you know so
I went over with him we both got into
that little mountain you had Foxhole and
if we'd have been hit we couldn't move
enough to even shoot out of it you know
yeah yeah so we laid on the back of it
at night when it got dark because we had
a spooky come in and we got out our
strobe lights put them down in the
foxholes uh and uh to outline our
perimeter and smart boy I'll tell you
when you're down on the ground those
traces uh seem to give the appearance
that they're coming straight down at you
but right at the last minute they seem
to bend and Veer off into the terrain
around the side but we had a good we had
air support all night long continually
oh wow and one of the airstrikes from
one of the Jets with hard bombs hit an
enemy ammo dump
and there were secondary explosions for
about three or four hours still and in
between it was better the Fourth of July
it was like a popcorn popper going off
all the AK around
the sky was like the flares or anything
like that
uh no uh but uh I'll tell you you know I
was in my Foxhole I said boy we hit
something big good then I says
the NBA gonna be ticked off now they're
going to come down here and kill us
right
I prayed that night man I promise to be
a better person if they'd let us get out
of there all of us and uh anyway we
survived into the morning and uh uh we
took 45 wounded on that operation
and uh
a number of them were critical you know
but uh that was the other that was the
biggest operation I was involved with
and how does Swain end up did he did he
survive all that oh yeah he he was at
the reunion here both he and Tom Yeager
were here really yep then what we're
referring to is because this being
recorded on October 22nd from October
the 18th through the 21st yeah into this
morning uh was a special operations
association annual reunion the 45th
annual reunion which you and I attended
for quite a few years now exactly and uh
so that's where they made it I didn't
realize they were here yeah and that's
quite a story and again the Medics our
SF Medics bring it back yeah well uh I
remember I first met you after joining
the special ops Association here indeed
yeah I joined in 92 came to my first
soar in 95 and I used to read uh you
know at the beginning you didn't read
much about SOG right there was a book
that I subscribed to Soldier of Fortune
that's a magazine magazine right well a
book I call magazines books but uh
anyway the uh uh there was a someone
named Isaac stats that was writing these
articles about SOG in this
magazine and uh icg I never I never knew
anybody named stats that was in there
but uh then when I joined I met you here
and uh you had in the 90s I think
started putting some things in with your
fullness your name yeah that's right
yeah is John Striker Meyer uh tilt to
all of us and uh it was it was shortly
after that I found out Isaac stats and
it was the striker Meyer were one in the
same small world yeah indeed and that's
when I started telling you you got to
put all those stories together into a
book dealt and then after I started
doing that I said Joe you got to put
your stories into a book and So speaking
about your books the very first book
that you co-authored with Bob Dumont
yeah the first one was titled SOG Medics
stories from Vietnam and over defense so
that one was printed by Paladin which
thoulette impress Paladin press yeah and
then
um you did a second edition that you
added some more information expanded the
Expanded Edition literally was that by
Palestine or did you have to go
somewhere else for that we had to go
somewhere else Paladin went out of
business and when they did they turned
all of the rights for the book over to
back to Bob and I and so Bob had uh some
contacts with the casemate publishers
and they did it Bob did a book with case
mate with one of my Medics classmates
called boxy
oh is that right which is about a medic
that yes served on an A-Team at Loch nin
yes so uh anyway historic battle locked
in so he had an in now with casemate and
uh uh so they redid the book and of
course there's been changes because in
the first book I would have says the
helicopter pilot came in and got shot
down now I can say uh Carl Hoke of the
uh 57th game yeah and I even know his
crew members have been added to the new
book you know so sure trying to make it
a little more historically accurate
indeed and then uh so you did the second
edition and so now you and Bob are
working on a third book yeah and this is
the most difficult one because
while Joe paner the medic was on his
second practice Mission other people
were doing real missions where they were
getting
Awards getting shot up and in real
missions I'm trying to tell this story
but it's much more difficult when you
weren't there
indeed
[Laughter]
it helps to have that first hand on the
ground experience yeah it's been a slow
progress on it because uh you know
sometimes you get to somebody with
questions and you know that isn't the
priority of their life your book and
stuff like that so it may take you six
months to get the answers to those
questions and uh welcome to the world of
book writing and we worked from award
orders a lot and as much as we can and
sure enough to try to fact check things
no you've been very good about that I
know from first-hand experience yeah
well I it's important to me to get it
right you know really
um we're at that point uh Joe I think uh
we're close to wrapping it up here is
there any final thoughts or anything as
you look back on your one-year tour Duty
and SOG and uh life there after any
final thoughts sir
well I'm glad I did it I have no regrets
and I'd do it all again
well then on that note
um that'll bring us to the end of our
podcast and again we thank Jocko willink
and his team for making these Saw cast
possible
and we also thank all of our military
service members for today they are
keeping our country safe and we also
thank the First Responders border patrol
different law enforcement agencies
even the FBI which sometimes has some
negative headlines lately and uh we also
want to make sure that we thank the men
and women who served our country for
years past and like Joe parner here
today are what we would call Heroes who
defended the values of America and Joe
we thank you for that and last but not
least we also remember and salute the
men and women who served our country and
who have not come home and as of today
2021 there are
1584 Americans that are still listed as
missing in action
uh from the Vietnam War in Southeast
Asia which would include Laos Cambodia
and our special operations Association
had a memorial breakfast where
we mentioned the name and saluted a
tribute paid tribute to
132 Americans just from the secret War
alone
50 plus Green Berets who remained
missing in accident today
as well as the additional Airmen the
aviators that died supporting SOG teams
on the ground
and that is includes uh Marine Corps
assets that supported us throughout the
entire war in the top secret War army
and Air Force and occasionally like your
case you had Navy dropping bombs and
supporting you all
and it was a war
hidden from the American public
but now people like yourself are writing
books and we're thankful for that
God Bless America until next time
thank you to airborne